wir wollen jetzt erstmal darüber
sprechen was da auf der Krim passiert
ist und zwar den Raketeneinschlag in
Sevastopol und das mache ich jetzt mit
dem Militärexperten Christian Mölling er
ist stellvertretender Direktor des
Forschungsinstituts der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik und
Leiter des Zentrums für Sicherheit und
Verteidigung hallo herrling hallo
gelernte Wortmann ja eine ukrainische
Rakete trifft offenbar das Hauptquartier
der russischen Schwarzmeerflotte ist das
aus ukrainischer Perspektive ein
militärischer Erfolg
da sind nur noch abwarten müssen was die
sagen das sogar damage assessment bringt
es gibt Gerüchte darüber dass zu dem
Zeitpunkt ein wichtiges Treffen in dem
Hauptquartier stattgefunden hat es ist
aber insofern schon auf alle Fälle ein
politischer Erfolg weil man damit
demonstriert das nicht einmal das
Hauptquartier der Schwarzmeerflotte
offensichtlich effektiv noch durch
Russland geschützt werden kann
nehmen Sie uns gerne einmal mit warum
ist über die Krim wurde in den
vergangenen Monaten ja immer viel
gesprochen aber warum ist Sebastopol ein
so strategisch wichtiges Ziel also was
du cool ist der Haupthafen der
Schwarzmeerflotte auch traditionell ganz
lange die russische und sowjetischer
Hafen gewesen
etwas wo die Flotte auch selbst zu einem
gewissen Teil heute noch anwesend ist
von daher ist das natürlich ein ein
Schlag nicht nur gegen einen militärisch
sondern auch historisches Ziel dass die
Russen lange mit sich selber und mit der
Sowjet Zeit verbunden haben und wir
haben ja eben auch auf der Karte sehen
können dass es sehr weit im Südwesten
liegt das heißt also man ist in der Lage
nahezu alle Ziele auf der Krim zu
treffen auch das ist ein Teil der
Nachrichten ausgesendet wird
sie sagen es ist ein sehr wichtiges Ziel
warum gelingt es der Ukraine bzw warum
gelingt es Russland so es ist richtig
dann diesen Punkt diesen Ort des
Hauptquartier nicht besser zu schützen
also offensichtlich ist die Ukraine in
den letzten Wochen das haben wir alle
miterlebt immer in Einzel Nachrichten
sehr erfolgreich gewesen die Luftabwehr
die Luftverteidigung rund um die
Sebastopol auszuschalten es hat auch
gestern schon den Treffer in einem
Kommunikationszentrum gegeben das 17 km
entfernt ist von Sebastopol also hier
muss man glaube ich einfach die die
einzelnen Tagesmeldung zusammen nehmen
und sagen die Krim ist mittlerweile ich
will nicht sagen in das Zentrum gerückt
aber es ist ein wesentlicher Teil der
Angriffsziele der Ukraine zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt und ich glaube es deutet
darauf hin dass wir langsam aber sicher
auf die Hochphase der Offensive zu
laufen
geht es dann dabei tatsächlich bei
dieser Hochphase der Offensive auch wenn
wir jetzt auf die Krim schauen um eine
Rückeroberung der Krim oder vielleicht
viel mehr darum den Russen da den
Nachschub abzuschneiden
ich glaube bei den Treffern geht es
nicht so sehr um den Nachschub dafür ist
dir was zu Polen nicht wichtig so was zu
tun könnte wichtig werden und zumindest
die Schiffe die dort liegen wenn die
Russen sich zurückziehen müssten von der
Krim oder aus dem Süden der Ukraine das
könnte auch einen Fall sein hier geht es
eigentlich eher darum die Krim auch in
den Augen Russlands so militärisch und
haltbar zu machen dass man sich an den
Verhandlungstisch bewegt das ist ja das
was selenskin seinen Friedensplan und
nochmal deutlich gemacht hat und ist
bereit über die Ukraine zu verhandeln
über die Krim zu verhandeln man muss es
nicht mit einem militärischen Sieg
sozusagen zu Ende gehen lassen
gleichzeitig steht er dahinter natürlich
auch die Nachricht wenn Russland sich
nicht zurückzieht von der krimin dann
wird natürlich der angeht weitergehen
weil die krimteile Ukraine ist
Hämmerling wir hören heute außerdem das
ist laut russischen Behörden auf der
Krim zu einem Zitat beispiellosen
Cyberangriff gekommen sei was kann ein
solcher Cyberangriff da tatsächlich
bewirken
das hängt von den einzelnen Details ab
die ich jetzt zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
nicht kenne aber zu glauben dass ein
Cyberangriff nur dazu führt dass Ihr
Computer nicht mehr geht ist halt falsch
in Zeiten in denen Software ein
wesentlicher Bestandteil auch von
militärischen Operationen ist das heißt
wir müssen etwas genauer wissen was
passiert ist aber man kann mittlerweile
davon ausgehen dass Cyberangriffe
durchaus tödliche Folgen haben können
wenn sie in der Lage sind bestimmte
kritische Infrastrukturen stillzulegen
wasserstill zu legen Energieanlagen
stillzulegen aber dafür bedarf es ein
bisschen mehr Informationen was genau
passiert ist dann lassen Sie uns gerne
mal einen Blick richten auf den
Frontverlauf das passt auch schon gut zu
fragen die wir bei Youtube bekommen und
zwar fragt uns ein User wie stark ist
der Durchbruch bei der Waffe wer war
vielleicht einmal zur Einordnung das ist
im Gebiet saporicia da sollen ich habe
es Eingang schon gesagt ukrainische
Panzer erstmals hinter dem russischen
Verteidigungsgürtel gesichtet worden
sein
wir sehen das auf der Karte jetzt auch
noch mal gut dass der amerikanische
Think Tank spricht ISW spricht davon
dass es noch zu früh sei von einem
Durchbruch tatsächlich zu sprechen wie
schätzen Sie die Situation dort ein ja
genau ich glaube das ist eine Nachricht
die sich auf gesicherte Informationen
von gestern bezieht das ist auch sehr
richtig man kann nicht jeden jeden
Wimpernschlag der dort passiert
nachvollziehen weil viele Berichte auch
in den sozialen Medien teilweise
übertrieben sind auch übertriebene
Erfolge Melden von daher ist es richtig
dass das zumindest jetzt der gesicherte
Stand ist aber auch da kritisch zu sein
ist auch richtig denn natürlich wird
Russland darauf reagieren russland hat
kein Interesse daran dass dieser
Durchbruch weitergeht das heißt es ist
jetzt vor allem die Frage ob Prozent in
der Lage ist neue Truppen heranzuführen
und quasi dieses diese Erweiterung
dieses Loch ist jetzt zu stoppen oder
aber ob es genug auch diese Gegenwert
zurück zu schlagen und was in dem
Zusammenhang ist wichtig ist darauf
kommen wir gleich noch zu sprechen ist
es ist nämlich nur einer ein
Frontabschnitt an den gekämpft wird
sondern es sind weitere Frontabschnitte
an denen die Aktivitäten hochgehen das
heißt Russland kommt in das Dilemma sich
entscheiden zu müssen wohin es seine
wenigen Reserven jetzt eigentlich packen
möchte genau mein Anschlussfrage wäre
gewesen also sie sagen Russland muss
zusehen wie es mit seinen reservenhaus
haltet worauf kommt es jetzt aus
ukrainischer Perspektive an damit diese
in diesem Fall ist es ja womöglich noch
kein Durchbruch aber damit diese
einzelnen Fortschritte die da erzählt
werden tatsächlich auch zu einem aus
ukrainischer Sicht Erfolg führen können
er ist auf der einen Seite dass man den
Truppen die jetzt diesen Durchbruch
durchführen tatsächlich den den Raum und
die Zeit verschafft weiter voranzukommen
das bedeutet eben Reserven die jetzt
angeführt werden
aufzuhalten so dass sie nicht an die
Front herankommen können Sie im Anmarsch
sowohl immer es geht schon zu zerstören
wenn sie überhaupt unterwegs sind und
damit tatsächlich den den Raum des
Durchbruches der ja schon auf der Seite
wir haben das wir sehen links quasi also
westlich weiter davon schon weiter
vorangeht so breit zu machen dass man
auf einer breiten Front mit gepanzerten
Fahrzeugen hier im Grunde genommen
weiter vorankommen kann aber man muss
auch sagen damit ist es noch nicht zu
Ende man ist noch nicht am
also schon mehr angekommen wir sehen
auch hier noch mal schön auf der Karte
es gibt noch weitere sperlinien die
Frage ist weiterhin wie gut die besetzt
sind durch die Russen also wie gut sie
sich selber verteidigen können und wie
viel Reserven die Ukraine in der Lage
ist jetzt nach vorne zu bringen damit
der Angriff nicht aufgehalten werden
kann genau sie sagen ein Ziel zum Ersatz
für mehr vor zurückdenken um dort eben
den Russen auch die Landverbindung zu
können abzuschneiden ist das was das
ihrer Sicht ein Zeitner realistisches
Ziel ist das ist ja noch ein ganz schön
weiter Weg dahin ne
ja das ist immer eine Frage von von
Tempo und Risiko ja also man kann
natürlich versuchen einen Durchbruch zu
wagen das kann aber auch bedeuten dass
der schief geht das haben wir ja in der
Anfangsphase gesehen ich glaube nicht
oder ich würde mal so rum sagen die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass man jetzt bis
zum also auch schon mehr kommt bzw die
Möglichkeit hat die Logistik im Süden
der Ukraine abzuschneiden ist jetzt
nicht über 50%. das ist aber nicht
schlimm denn die Ukraine plant ja im
Grunde genommen schon für die nächste
Offensive das muss sie jetzt auch tun
die Zeit ist bald abgelaufen um diese
Offensive nach vorne zu treiben aber mit
dem nächsten Jahr kommen natürlich dann
auch neue Waffen wir wissen dass die
amerikanischen Panzer dann eintreffen
werden und das ist im Grunde genommen
das was man jetzt schon ins Auge fassen
muss die Winterzeit auf der einen Seite
und die nächste Offensive die jetzt
vorbereiten muss und besser vorbereiten
muss als die letzte und das bedeutet
natürlich auch dass die Europäer und
Amerikaner ihrem Beitrag leisten müssen
damit es dieses Mal besser läuft als
beim letzten Mal
eine Frage die uns noch bei Youtube
erreicht und zwar von Randolph
Armbruster der fragt gibt es
Informationen darüber ob russische
Kräfte westliche Panzer die beschädigt
wurden für sich selbst einsetzen haben
sie dazu irgendwelche Informationen ich
habe keine Informationen in dieser
Richtung bislang gehört
die Frage ist dann auch wenn sie so ein
Panzer erobert haben müssen sie auch
noch die passende Munition haben die
Munition die die russischen Panzer
verschießen hat nicht das Gleiche
Kaliber wie das der westlichen Panzer in
den meisten Fällen zumindestens
überlegen aber ich glaube das ist so der
Fall das heißt selbst wenn so ein Panzer
haben dann ist das ein schönes
Propaganda Stück dass sie da haben aber
dass sie das einsetzen können auch ohne
das entsprechende Training die Ukrainer
mussten ja auch erstmal auf den
konzentriert werden das ist ja noch eine
zweite Aufgabe also das eignet sich
sicherlich zu einer Art von Propaganda
Parade aber das damit der Mehrwert der
russischen Streitkräfte gestärkt wird
das würde ich eher verneinen okay es
soll ja außerdem Fortschritte aus
ukrainische perspekt Olive bei Bach Mut
geben welche Informationen haben Sie
darüber ja sowohl bachmute als auch
weiter südlich schreiten offensichtlich
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte
schrittweise voran das ist ja eine
Operation gewesen die man sehr
kontrolliert in den letzten Wochen so
gehalten hat dass Russland sich
weiterhin in der Stadt aufhalten konnte
weil es einfach so ein Symbol ist das
nicht aus russischer Sicht eigentlich
nicht fallen darf und eben die Tatsache
dass da jetzt parallel zu der
verstärkten Angriffen im Süden und den
erfolgreichen
taktischen Durchbrüchen im Süden quasi
das Tempo angezogen wird
deutet darauf hin dass man jetzt
tatsächlich in eine Phase kommt wo man
versucht für die russenriedige Probleme
aufzumachen dass sie einfach nicht mehr
wissen wo sie ihre Truppen hinstellen
können denn der
bachmut wie gesagt dass er ein
politisches Symbol weil man enorm viele
Ressourcen da reingesteckt hat das zu
erobern es ist auch in den Gebieten von
denen man Anfang versprochen hat dass
man sie erobern will gleichzeitig ist
der Süden natürlich umso wichtiger denn
sobald die Ukraine Amazon schon mehr
stehen ist die Krim wahrscheinlich für
Russland nicht mehr militärisch einfach
oder gar nicht mehr zu verteidigen das
heißt die haben sie zwei Abwägungen die
Russland jetzt schon treffen muss und
dazu kommen noch ein dritter Angriff
eine dritte Front in der Mitte